hello Jerry jacks I'm Greg Alva this
with me here is Lisa Malik
thank you Lisa mihalick is awesome and
talented she is working on a cool movie
right now and she took time out of her
busy schedule to skate on by do this
video with us early I just took my
skates off and we really appreciate this
about you
you know what the promise the camera
feels so far away yeah I'm like I miss
people I need to feel connected oh there
we go we're much closer now we're good
all right split official trailer number
two um I don't think you've heard of
this movie Lisa doesn't get out enough
to watch movies oh thank you so much and
thanks for having me yeah of course I do
know Lisa from acting class and there's
this movie coming up where I think it's
a great like character study kind of
film if it turns out well should we do a
scene from it I don't think you can you
have to watch this to understand Wow
whoa you've seen this before you've
emailed for an appointment two days in a
row it's going on I've never seen cases
like this before
23 identities live in Kevin's body
what is the ring happen oh there's a
flower on the pillars a flower in the
bathroom like we're important who is
that maybe she can help us don't worry
he knows what you're here for
he's not allowed to touch you he knows
that what Hedwig I have read that
the human brain is the most complex want
you to come help us okay baby
that's here close now it's open new
route oh you could leave an individual
with multiple personalities can change
their body chemistry with their thoughts
nice what will happen when he unlocks
the potential of his brain there is no
limit to what we can become there is a
sacred night you will be in the presence
of something greater the world will
understand that the beast is real
ouch
he's done awful thank the people and
he'll do awful things to you
whoa let's just take a minute whoa
that's rather show a lot whoa whoa he's
a good actor I know right he's a really
good actor 23 different personalities I
mean in class we just have to hit up one
maybe two if they're bipolar I feel like
we're gonna really see him do like many
different characters like it's not just
gonna be like a two dimensional change I
have a feeling that every time he's a
different person he has a full character
to that it's not like he has quirks and
mannerisms
it's not gonna be two-dimensional it's
gonna be a fold yeah embodiment of
another character I'm excited for that I
want to see this I don't normally like
it looks scary I don't normally like go
for the scary stuff but I would see this
it doesn't look scary actually is
alarming like you never know what
personality you're gonna get you know
what That's Life that's life too isn't
it that's right
yeah man Trump just saying uh right now
Trump is in the lead from the time we're
filming this video at times videos up we
will know whether or not Trump is in
fact president on the United States of
America stop um he was leaving the
country I too have a split personality
it's called a trump supporter oh my god
I told you guys this whole time
Trump would win I was never sarcastic
I was never doing satire making fun of
Trump supporters it was all very sincere
and I totally called it John you owe me
$50 I have a whole character to that
yeah
yeah that was really nice what you did
there was good thank you yeah
aa great example great exam an example
of what he's doing am i doing but 20 but
22 more times
yeah one thing that was kind of worrying
me about the trailer was I liked it when
it was like just a psychological
thriller like this guy is 23 different
personalities yeah but then they got
like a little crazy towards the end with
like him changing his body yeah oh that
beast becoming real that friend she did
yeah portions with his neck and back and
I'm like if he goes like full beast mode
I'm wondering if we're able gonna do
really gonna be able to buy that right
be a little too much yeah yeah yeah it's
not like he ripped out of his skin and
became like Incredible Hulk that would
be too much that would that would be too
okay no thank you
too corny now you know I totally agree
with you yeah okay I'm serious
I I'm serious - too much buttons but
that didn't happen
that is not cranked a little it kind of
made I hate but at the end when yeah
when you see the little girl and she's
looking over and she's hearing that
little beast roar yeah you know maybe he
becomes a beast maybe maybe it's like
beauty and everything
maybe it's like Beauty and the Beast you
know when is it coming out uh January
January scary month only nine months
away from Halloween yeah this just looks
like a really cool film to me in total
in total though besides not one worried
I really feel like this is gonna be a
cool film what's gonna matter most like
despite how the plot might turn out I
feel like if James McAvoy does an
awesome job as it looks like he will do
an awesome job yeah I feel like even if
the plot doesn't play out that well if
his performance is amazing people will
still recommend yeah you know yeah well
the plot is gonna be crazy anyway
because of all the different yes
nowadays he hits I don't know there's
gonna be it who knows maybe a lot of
different plots who knows yeah we got 23
different moves I mean that 2375
alright rejects subscribe today and get
accepted less of a colleague um is a
busy woman doing busy things we shot a
short film oh yeah it's going up on
Blume houses social media if we're
almost done with it
it's funny it has a lot has a lot of
texture in it thank you you really
helped out with that she's a lead
actress in it she's also doing are
giving us a title ice the movie it's
called ice the movie
oh it's called move ice ice
that's the follower on Instagram
and uh I told you all dong humble one
stop we don't know that yet I know we
don't know that yeah but um thank you
psychic
yeah that's when I pointed this video
out and say hey I'm in a trump supporter
this whole time we've seen how it
Baldwin's impression no is it good have
you seen Jimmy Fallon's impression so
Alec Baldwin's is bad that's cold
really you haven't seen okay I haven't
seen Baldwin no but Jimmy man he's the
man the man he's the man man he's so I
got up to Jimmy